so you changed you had two different
outfits for wow you distracted me with
the boyfriend question huh cause he
totally just dropped the B word as in
boyfriend yeah I don't know what's
scarier that was having to talk about my
boyfriend on TV or having that happen
right a scary thing it all went down on
Wednesdays Ellen DeGeneres Show when
Ellen
showed Hosey a pic of her and Evan
dressed as Sonny and Cher for Halloween
well then there's that one then you were
also shared i was share yeah and whose
Sonny
it's Evan Peters okay
so if you need a little back story on
evident Halsey we got you the pair got
together pretty recently but made things
official this past weekend first Holly
posted this shot of the pair at her
Halloween bash then they were wearing
those Sonny and Cher costumes at the
American Horror Story 100th episode
party but things could have been just a
little awkward
Evans ex and former co-star and the
Roberts was also there yeah awkward it's
hard just dating in general Emma and
Evan were of course together for years
starting back in 2012
she's since moved on with Garrett
Hedlund and Halsey was most recently
linked to Youngblood I think the thing
that's like really cool for us is both
of us are total control freaks we don't
listen to anyone but each other
sometimes you meet someone and you just
have a really good rhythm though she
recently addressed their breakup in a
now-deleted tweet quote sometimes people
just break up
it doesn't mean someone cheated or
something bad happened or someone effed
up sometimes it just happens because
life is constantly changing and adults
stay friends and move on
very mature I'm doing well and the
people I love are happy and taking care
of and
everything is good and of course before
that she was wind she easy she's
brilliant yeah she was really brilliant
she's an amazing person she's so
intelligent so insightful but back to
Holly on Ellen she also talked about her
collab with BTS
[Music]
and had nothing but nice things to say
you broke the Guinness World Book of
Records for the most amount of views in
the shortest amount of time yes with BTS
yeah yeah how was that working for those
guys they're awesome they're very
popular he they are very very popular
they're super awesome and they really
made me feel at home like a family all
right guys that is it for today for all
the latest make sure that you keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie crafts
and bye for now
[Music]